you know first let's talk about the
times that we're living in now everybody
is going through it this is the one
thing that's unifying us all is that
we're all going through this at the same
time and I'm wondering how you're
navigating how you're getting through
yourself it's been very interesting for
me it's being kind of a very spiritual
moment I know myself better I've been
touring for almost eight years something
like that so now that I had to stop
because I was in Europe I was in Greece
when all these things that happening and
I had to come right away to to Colombia
so so it was like like I had to stop by
but that was a good stop for me you know
because I need to share some time with
my family also I need I need to share
some time in my house I have a house
that I'm never here this is my studio
where I record all my music and and I'm
never here you know so so it's been very
nice actually I learned how to record
myself again I went back to to read
books to see TV shows you know it's like
it's like going back to the basic you
know so it feels it feels good cooking
myself you know my own meals stop for a
second one what is it that you cook that
you think you're really good at what is
that well the hot water is a man like if
I came over for dinner
what meal would you prepare well you
know do you know when they have lights
out no i don't but okay but i'm sure
okay
next time next time all these thing is
over you're gonna come to Columbia
you're gonna come to my house I'm gonna
cook up and they help ice up for you
okay
it's beans we rise early plantain I'm
gonna I'm gonna keep cooking this time
so when you come here I'm gonna be a
real chair ma I really will take you up
on that no I mean and this is the thing
about it the Latino community has been
hit especially hard as you know and I
know you feel very very passionate about
the community what is your message to
them and what are you doing to try to
help okay so so happy this foundation
that is called the art of dreams dream
in a larger Los Suenos so when all these
coronavirus things started we realized
that the real crisis was in the parents
of the families right because they
couldn't go out to make money right so
they couldn't get food so what we deep
is getting some food and send him
sending the the foot and because they
they were starving and and that was a
very critical situation that we were
living so I think that of course my
message for the Latin community is that
we have to be competitive we have to be
patient that all this thing is gonna be
over sooner than later that I'm here for
help him that they have this foundation
that that can help them in many ways and
just to believe in God and and and keep
the faith I think that that's very
important - I heard that you donated
ventilators and masks you did that so
that there are different hospitals here
around my hometown they don't have masks
anymore not even gloves so we took that
we took advantage of the whole situation
and we we we got them for for them so so
yeah that was another way to help him
you know I was looking at your Instagram
you must tell us what a D and B means
you're teasing us you're teasing us
should I tell you yes well but this is
very exclusive actually this is like all
the more reason why you should tell us
look at us okay so a DMV is my new
single this song is gonna be released
next Friday I'm so excited about it
amor de mi vida in English is love of my
life yes I am love of your life yes I
love of my life I wrote this song for
you love my life
I like this idiom okay yeah so I'm very
excited about it I wrote this song in
January in a musical camp that I had in
Jamaica and actually the day that I
wrote this song I had to be in the
Grammys where I had to fly to Vegas to
be at Grammys but that's destiny that's
how it works that's how the world works
and all and how God make all the plans
so I couldn't go to Vegas I wrote this
song and next week I decided that it had
to be my my next single so I'm very
excited about it it's a very very
special song because all the things that
we live in right now and yeah I hope you
you like it I'm gonna be reading I'm
sure I will like it I'm just so sorry
listen this is the thing about your
music for me I confess I don't know a
word of what you're saying if I often
wish that I could speak another language
other than Pig Latin and I really wish I
could speak Spanish because not you know
- it's a universal language but I want
to know what is he saying what is he
saying and there's something about for
women you lost me with four women you
don't need for women one you don't need
more women but your music your voice and
your and the way you dance in a way you
know it's so infectious it's so
infections to me it's yeah yeah when you
have my mom if you need any help dating
I know it's very hard for you I'll be
happy to fix you up I need your help
these are home because I'm single
actually are you being serious single no
are you yeah I'm single I've been single
forever for a while yeah but you must
want to be
right do you want to be single at this
period in your yeah yeah
to be honest it's not my priority right
now to be in a relationship I feel like
my career is growing and I have to
invest my energy my mind and everything
I got in my career and and also my mind
is in my foundation you know so I'm
helping people I don't really I really
feel that I need to be in a relationship
so I'm good for now hey one maybe this
is a time for a lot of people to work on
yourself do you ever think about that
maybe yeah actually in these difficult
times I've been meditating a lot I've
been knowing myself I've been reading a
lot I've been making music that I really
love you know it's like like going back
to myself so I really needed this time
to but this is a thing 1 what people
need to understand that I now know your
story is so amazing what you have done
what you pulled off at 26 years old is
so fascinating to me but you knew as a
little kid that you wanted to be famous
you had a choice it seems between soccer
and music and it seems like the two of
them competed for a while yeah yeah your
heart went to music why well when I
started my career I was 16 years old and
I was playing soccer for almost eight
years so it was a very difficult
decision to me because I was in love of
my soccer career you know my my dad he
thought that I was gonna be a
professional soccer player he used to
come with me to every game so so yeah I
thought I was gonna be a professional
absolutely but then I decided to start
composing music I used to write these
letters for my friends so so I decided
that that I wanted to start singing
because because I really love music so I
told my aunt that I wanted to go to
studio but in that time my dad he got
broke so we lost everything right
everything we we got we we lost so
I was feeling the necessity to be the
like the head of the family right yeah
exactly it was very very young so I told
my aunt that I really wanted to to go to
studio and maybe maybe maybe try to make
a life of music right so I went for the
first time and I just fall in love with
everything about it I keep going I made
a lot of music then I was one day my
house and and my mom she was very sad
because all the things out they were
happening I was like mom you have to
keep the faith you know that that this
is this is a tough moment that we live
in but but I'm pretty sure that we're
gonna see the light boy have you seen
the light I mean I talk about your life
today because here you are at arenas
17,000 people 18,000 people
all screaming maluma baby some Oh baby I
love that where did my Lou my baby come
from I love that you do that where did
that come from well actually that was my
fans
one day I'll open a tweet to one someone
sent a tweet and then say like my Lou my
baby a huge friend my baby and then he
said it and then it was like my baby
well it sounds good my Lou my baby and
they yeah it's certainly a term of
endearment but I wonder what it's likely
that little kid who was dance in the
mirror who really worked very very hard
that's the thing about you you worked
very hard to get to this couple of
success and now that you're here what
does it feel like for you to be on stage
and you look out and you see everybody
is just knowing all the words really
similar cheering you what does that feel
like for you in your heart it's like I
you know to be honest I feel like proud
of myself you know because I dream about
it
a long time ago and a lot of people they
told me that that was impossible you
know I'm not so many doors and
well most of them they didn't open you
know and they were allowed this guy's
crazy first at the beginning he wanted
to be a soccer player and now he wants
to sing well he's that he's broken and
what's gonna happen with his life and I
was like okay give me give me some give
me couple of years and then you guys are
gonna see how how how powerful it could
be our mind right and then I keep
working and and I feel I feel proud of
my team too you know I couldn't I
couldn't be what I am right now without
them so so yeah I feel feel proud I feel
it is just the beginning actually you
know and I'm just starting I'm 26 years
old right now and I feel like the best
things in my lab they're about to come
yes I believe grateful grateful grateful
grateful with God and my fans to know I
believe maluma I so believe that one you
really are just getting started and I'm
fascinated that at this level of Fame
you have made the decision so many
people cross over and think they have to
sing in English I've heard you say
you've made the decision that you don't
ever plan to sing in English why that
you're not comfortable singing in
English no no actually like three years
ago I went to Los Angeles I went to
studio with the most important producers
of the musical industry work with sky
storage Timberland I mean all of them
are and grinders producers all of them
and they did like seven or eight songs
in English and I loved the experience
was great but at the end when I listened
to her songs I was like oh my god that
that's not me
you know like like I felt like I was
Justin Bieber's competition or something
like that you know I don't want to be
like that you know myeloma is my lumen
and is my genre is my essence that's
what I wanted people to believe about me
and my career
of course I love singing in English
actually I grew up listening to hip-hop
listening to R&B listening to rap to
jazz to soul right and all these songs
they were in English right but then when
I
mixed of these American roots with with
the Latin roots or what I am right now
that was the key of my career you know
because I'll always saw the American
culture as something that I wanted to
get or something that I wanted to be
right but at the end of the day I'm
Latin right so I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna stop singing in Spanish because I
want to conquer them America no the
global world I think that if I'm myself
I can I can conquer the world being
myself singing in Spanish I don't I
don't need to to copy someone to to be
what I'm gonna be I believe a hundred
percent of my essence I believe a
hundred percent of my culture and I want
to beat that around the world
can I just one you have conquered the
world but I heard you said that when you
when you sang in Spanish when you sang
in English rather sorry it felt like you
were reading is that what you said that
it felt like tell me about tell me that
yeah yeah I love I love the English
right but so to me is kind of difficult
to to sing it you know legs I don't I
don't know I don't know why maybe
because I'm very used to to singing
Spanish right or something like that but
yeah I feel more comfortable singing in
Spanish I can write actually in English
I wrote before a couple song in English
but I feel I feel better doing it in
Spanish and I think that's what your
fans like but that's what I love about
you that you have a very strong sense of
who you are and what to be you have a
very strong sense of that Shakti
yeah and listen so far one it's working
for you it's working for you yeah you
know but I got confused once in my
career one day when when I went source
Angeles that I read told this story and
was like should I start singing in
English and they late like six months
later I went to East row right my first
concert in Israel and it was that oh my
god I'm I came to
to Israel I don't know what's gonna
happen I don't know if they're gonna
sing my songs I'm pretty sure that they
speak English but then I speak Spanish
and then I one stage and there were
30,000 people during a huge arena in
Israel singing every word of my songs in
Spanish and and it was like I was like
this is the message that I needed to
receive to understand that then my music
it has to be in Spanish you know and and
I have to be proud of myself and proud
of my culture and keep showing to the
whole world where I'm coming from but
we're very very excited about the global
citizen performance are you going to be
performing well I'm gonna perform a song
that I wrote like five years ago
that is called corona while the hook is
very special for me because it says like
there's no way you my case will free yes
one is one kind of no you don't have to
cry to have to suffer because life is
one and it's a carnival so that's like
the that's like the real meaning of the
whole song and gravity they chose me to
to to make these amazing appearance
right because I feel like this is gonna
be huge and being the only ours that is
performing in Spanish that's big you
know that's that's important for me
that's that's like an anthem for the for
the Latin community so I feel very very
happy about it
and I hope you guys enjoy the
performance I did it here in my house of
course what does it mean to you one that
listen they could have chosen anybody
but they chose you what does that mean
it is a very well page and it is global
yeah yeah I'm so grateful about it I'm
pretty honored to you know this is a big
big deal to be there performing there
are a lot of huge stars around the world
you know and and they chose me to be
part of it so so yeah I did this
performance I did it in a very organic
way and yeah I feel I feel like it's an
honor to be part of it you know what
else I like I like that you are someone
who loves his family your family is
every
your mom your dad your sister Manuela is
her name Manuela
yeah whoa yeah means everything to you
and so starting with maluma that's could
that be family what does that mean so my
mom's name is Margie my dad's name is
reason my sister's name is Manuela so I
took the first letters of each name and
I just put it together and that's how my
looma was created I really feel like
they are the engine of my career there
are my whole motivation I wouldn't be
anything without them they fed me they
they made me who I am right now they
gave me the values to to go through
these worlds so I feel like they're
they're everything to me that's that's
what that's why I gather my artistic
name and hey and not only that
everything I do my my life yeah all
right I know you have to go I'll end
with this because I know you said you
live in a place of gratitude that you
you feel grateful every day what are you
grateful for as we sit here today the
simple fact of being breathing I would
say that that's very important sometimes
we forget about it you know you because
you you wake up and you have everything
in your hands you know someone was
cooking for you you have a lot of
problems in your head you have a lot of
projects and then you just forget the
simple things in life as breathing so I
wake up every morning feeling grateful
being alive for me that's the most
important thing